derniers préparatifs avant l'arrivée du
souverain pontife en irak
à l'occasion de cette visite historique
les blasons aux couleurs du vatican sont
hissés en haut des poteaux électriques
certaines routes du pays refaite à neuf
non content est jamais été aussi
reluisante ici irakien musulmans comme
chrétiens attendent avec impatience cet
événement c'est une visite historique
on parle d'un chef religieux suivi par
20% de la population mondiale
sa venue veut dire beaucoup sa rencontre
avec le grand ayatollah ali al-sistani
aura un effet énorme je demande pas
françois d'apporter la sécurité et la
paix afin qu'il n'y ait plus de
différence entre les musulmans et les
chrétiens
toute autre confession nous espérons
qu'il y aura la paix et la sécurité
une visite qui relève d'un véritable
casse tête logistique dans un contexte
sécuritaire particulièrement tendu en
trois jours le pape françois va
parcourir plus de 1400 kilomètres par
les airs pour se rendre dans des sites
emblématiques du pays ce qui implique le
survol de certaines zones où se terrent
encore des djihadistes du groupe etat
islamique
un défi auquel s'ajoutent les tensions
entre les deux puissances
agissant en irak l'iran et les états
unis ce mercredi une dizaine de
roquettes se sont abattues sur une base
américaine dans l'ouest du pays
mais pas de quoi bouleverser l'agenda du
vatican pèlerine je viens en pèlerin
elle rappelait temps pour implorer du
seigneur pardon et réconciliation après
des années de guerre et de terrorisme
vie pour demander à dieu la consolation
des coeurs et la guérison des blessures
je viens en tant que pèlerin de la paix
des packs l'irak qui doit faire face à
des restrictions sanitaires adopter pour
endiguer la propagation du coronavirus
même si le pape et les responsables
ecclésiastiques ont pu être vaccinés
seul un très faible nombre d'irakiens
ont reçu une dose de sérum le nombre de
places pour les messes sera donc limitée
un confinement sera également décrété
durant toute la visite papale
le souverain pontife qui sera quant à
lui privé de ses bains de foule rituel